le gouvernement jeudi devant la stèle de
furiani furia lumière rouge a mis sa
parole est à monsieur marc philippe
daubresse
monsieur le premier ministre
dimanche dernier lors de la fête du
travail l'emploi des jeunes étaient au
centre de nos préoccupations à toutes et
à tous or vous venez de prendre en
quelques semaines trois décisions
totalement incohérente et improductive
en la matière la première sur le sujet
qui nous mobilise cet après midi la voix
travail
qu'est ce que vous avez fait un tête à
queue spectaculaire qui va aboutir à ne
pas rendre l'emploi plus flexible sur le
marché du travail et le code du travail
moins rigide ce qui fera baisser
forcément le front de l'offre d'emploi
et donc pénalisera en premier lieu les
jeunes demandeurs d'emploi
la seconde en vous prononçant pour la
garantie jeunes dans une négociation
pour contrebalancer un certain nombre de
choses avec les jeunes c'est à dire dans
un moment où l'argent public est de plus
en plus rares a consacré l'essentiel de
vos moyens sur une mesure coûteuse
vous allez m'expliquer que la garantie
jeunes ce une mesure de soutien
d'accompagnement de solidarité
d'inclusivité mais si vous aviez mis les
mêmes moyens sur la politique de
l'apprentissage et que vous ne l'aviez
pas sacrifier au début de ce mandat nous
n'en serions pas là aujourd'hui
et la troisième sur le rsa jeunes j'ai
préconisé comme monsieur sirugue que l'
on fusionne les minima sociaux sous le
précédent quinquennat
j'ai préconisé aussi que l'on
réfléchisse imprime d'activité oui au
rsa activité pour les jeunes qui ont une
activité mais non rsa généralisé qui
aboutit à un système d'assistanat
généralisé qui fait tout pour mettre les
jeunes au travail
donc ma question est simple qu'ont donc
allez vous nous présenter un plan sur
l'emploi des jeunes et non pas un
dispositif d'assistanat qu ils se
dénomment contrats et des garanties
jaune ou rsa jeunes
la parole est quand même myriam el
khomri ministre du travail de l'emploi
de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
marc philippe daubresse
vous auriez pu commencer votre
intervention en rappelant que le chômage
des jeunes a diminué en 2015 c'est une
réalité
c'est une réalité nous avons eu huit
mois de baisse de chômage des jeunes
sur l'année et c'est essentiel c'est
essentiel parce que nous savons bien
qu'aujourd'hui la première année ont
signé un cdi à 27 ans contre 22 ans il y
à plus de 15 ans donc en effet le
président de la république a fait une
priorité à la jeunesse et cette priorité
à la jeunesse
aujourd'hui la politique que nous
conduisons elle porte ses fruits
et c'est essentiel pourquoi nous avons
développé la garantie jeunes nous avons
d'abord expérimenté je pense que toute
bonne politique publique doit d'abord
être expérimenté nous avons expérimenté
dans de nombreux départements
et ce dispositif fonctionne il vit
justement pour des jeunes qui sont
sortis du système scolaire qui ne savent
pas véritablement où ils veulent aller
justement et qui sont en situation de
précarité de pouvoir rentrer dans un
dispositif d'accompagnement et je ne
laisserai pas dire ici et je suis
particulièrement précise là dessus que
la garantie jeunes ce n'est pas une
allocation la garantie jeunes c'est un
dispositif d'accompagnement pour des
jeunes volontaires et motivés qui
acceptent de rentrer dans un dispositif
et qui permet en plus de développer
l'information autour de l'apprentissage
qui est essentiel je ne nie pas que nous
avons en début de quinquennat en effet
sur la question de l'apprentissage
envoyer des messages qui ont pu être
contradictoires depuis depuis et c'est
essentiel de savoir reconnaître ses
erreurs
depuis nous avons pris de nombreuses
mesures les tpe jeunes apprentis décret
notamment sur la question de la
réglementation dangereuse et surtout
l'an dernier c'est près de 285 millions
d'euros qui sont allés en plus dans
l'apprentissage soyons honnêtes et
regardons les choses très en phase 5 %
d'augmentation des entrées en
apprentissage cette année c'est
essentiel et nous continuons et j'espère
que vous ferez le projet de loi que je
présenterai dans quelques minutes